all right let's take a little tour
through the mind of magga uh donald
trump holding this rally for mary miller
in mendon illinois over the weekend we
looked at some of the things donald
trump had to say we talked a little bit
about
things mary miller has said let's now
look at the attendees and i continue to
think that there's a bit of a split
between sort of like your normal
republicans with whom i still disagree
on policy but they're basically people
who like on a weekend
they might
you know
go to a tag sale or take their kids to
soccer or maybe you know even go to a
shooting range or whatever that there's
those republicans and then there's the
republicans that are willing to travel
to a trump rally and these are very
different people i'm not saying i love
the normal republicans political views
that's not what i'm saying but but there
is a distinction here and we're going to
start with a guy
who um
you know what i'm not even we're just
going to start with a guy okay let's
listen to what he had to say florida is
an old neurotoxin that's used to kill
rats
and the nazis used to put it with uh
stalin they'd had a 1936 world court
stop it right there then why hasn't
we've seen a lot of people drop dead
like rats that's a great question why
hasn't we've seen that's exactly the
question i would ask for brushing their
teeth with fluoride or using it see if
you give a low toxic dose see if you had
a massive dose of forehead you would die
now in your tube of toothpaste it does
say contact the emergency room if you
swallow a p drop size that actually has
that warning on the tube of toothpaste
and there are thousands of visits every
year for over fouridation toothpaste but
that's a minor issue putting it in the
water oh god do you know that that
extrapolated study for fluoride safety
was very simply done with topical
fluoride on a tooth in a laboratory
ingesting fluid was never studied kind
of like the sm-102 of the ingredient of
the vaccine okay so let's stop you right
there because i've got a lot of people
right now that are going wait a minute
he just said that if i swallow
toothpaste you have to go the emergency
you're gonna go to the emergency room
okay now normally it says
if more than is used for brushing is
swallowed like i know it doesn't even
matter you and you know and i know that
this is the you this these are
completely closed captioning
not
push that aside too available push all
chemicals on the chemical table to the
side real quickly how expert on
chemicals and biological warfare let's
not talk about that right now i want to
talk about how you got 15 million
democrats to vote for president trump oh
on a handshake and my reputation of
being the holistic uh guru of the world
you're shaking 15 million hands
so obviously that's very significant
mental illness and it's treated as
normal it's treated as political
discourse it's treated as
these are the constituents of a
political movement and we don't want to
stigmatize mental illness it's not about
making fun of it but it is important to
point out when you have a political
contingent that whose origins are a
complete disconnect from the real world
so when we talk about you know there's
gradations of this there's gradations
the comet ping pong stuff
that was that was heavily influenced by
complete paranoid delusions being
suffered by many of the people who were
promulgating that that stuff and it's
all gradations thinking taxes should be
lower
is not this this is on one end right
thinking we should have a lower tax rate
is on the other and in the middle
there's a whole bunch of different stuff
and much of it has just become accepted
as valid political discourse very very
crazy stuff here's one woman who was
asked what are trump's biggest
accomplishments this is a big trump fan
it's funny that she even struggles to
explain what they are on ground here
favorite thing that president trump did
while he was in office was what yeah
oh gosh
helping the military
military seems to be a very popular
subject i love how the interviewer is
like there you go it's almost like
dealing with someone who
can't think
and then they come up with something you
know like can you tell us what
what year is it well it's um
[Music]
it's 20
20
two yeah 20 22. good there you go i mean
he's he's treating her like she's an
invalid
uh but the point here is they don't even
know why they like trump yeah and
allowing more prayer yeah allowing more
prayer and helping the military are the
big accomplishments of trump here is a
gentleman who claims to be former law
enforcement who his big thing is uh gun
rights going to tell you i'm a retired
law enforcement hey i'm a lifetime
member of the nra yep i'm all about the
second amendment i feel safe standing
right next to you i'll tell you that
he's my next guest hey i'm all about
that i'm all about the second amendment
and what do you think
you know there's a special snowflake
feel to a lot of these trump supporters
and let me explain what i mean by that
um one of the things i've talked about
before
is that to some degree
this entire narrative
that exists
it's caricaturized as being more on the
left of everyone is special
and everyone is you know what whatever
that
sometimes taken too far it can sort of
create problems of self-centeredness and
um
etc where like yes we're all individuals
we all bring unique perspectives to the
table everyone deserves to have their
ideas uh uh heard and children should be
celebrated oh that's all that's all true
but at the same time we're all one of
eight billion people
and uh everybody has to kind of be part
of the collective and there's millions
of people that fall into every category
and we sort of like need some balance
when you go too far
one of the things that i get the feeling
of with some of these folks
is they believe that they they are
completely unique and above everything
else the law enforcement guy listen
i'm retired law enforcement and the
second amendment and this makes me
unique in my support for trump and how i
should be listened to it this is the
thing they criticize about the left they
go oh all these leftist special
snowflake well they kind of do the same
thing as a teacher who supports assault
rifles
i am here and i know that it is trump
that we need okay all right it's just
another opinion among hundreds of
millions like let's let's apply
some healthy skepticism to everyone's uh
perspective here to some degree okay
then we go to the next guy
um this guy doesn't know what's going on
i won't even introduce this when they
when the left uh media went berserk over
president trump drinking with two hands
or walking slow down an icy step i mean
this guy's falling up the stairs to
airplane water airplane won
three times and and where putin is out
ice skating and riding horses
and practicing their foreign affairs
which are really poor right now but
with the weak leader the rest all right
so anyway putin's strong and trump is
strong
but biden is weak that seems to be the
most important perspective and then
here's another woman asked about again
about trump's biggest accomplishment in
office and she struggles to these these
folks are struggling
favorite thing that trump did during uh
his tenure in the white house was what
just one thing
i'm putting on the spot for just one i'm
sure there's i mean i feel like he
really brought our country together for
once i mean i can't think of a president
at least in my lifetime that's brought
us together as a whole like that yeah
remember how united the country was
under trump that's uh that that's that's
pretty pretty interesting so
sometimes i wonder how these folks even
manage to feed themselves and many of
them raise kids i mean that's that's the
that's the incredible thing
but uh a very interesting and different
political constituency and the question
will be without trump on the ballot in
november
do they vote with trump gone from the
white house and not on the ballot do
they vote and do trumpian candidates win
in november
four and a half months and we'll have
that answer
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping